the president now says he will push
school officials to make sure students
return to the classroom this fall
he made his case during a White House
roundtable he claimed without giving
evidence that some officials want to
keep schools off-limits for reasons
other than the coronavirus we don't want
people to make political statements or
do it for political reasons I think it's
going to be good for them politically so
they keep the schools closed no way so
we're very much going to put pressure on
governor's and everybody else to open
the schools to get them open and it's
very important it's very important for
our country it's very important for the
well-being of the student and the
parents the CDC has guidelines for
schools that do reopen if the community
has a small to moderate transmission
rate it should cancel gatherings like
field trips or assemblies if there is a
significant transmission rate students
should be sent home for at least two
weeks
there's a lot to talk about here so
let's bring in CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus he joins us
from California doctor good morning if I
could I don't want to remove politics
completely from this conversation let's
talk medically is it okay for schools to
open in the fall can they do it and what
do they need to do to do it safely
your children are 1/3 to 1/2 less likely
to catch the virus or spread the virus
so that data seem to be holding up and
so I believe children should be in
school and I believe obviously parents
need that but we need to wear masks it
will be mandatory it should be mandatory
in all school districts for children to
wear masks they should be socially
distance as much as possible there
should be plan so there are no large
gatherings in the school and the school
should be redesigned to enable space for
the children in the class so they're not
right next to each other that will take
resources and time we have it now we
have to get on it across the country so
that schools can open yeah I was gonna
ask you is it realistic to expect that
schools will make those changes by next
month and and what do you make of
teachers and some teachers unions saying
look we're skeptical we don't feel it's
particularly safe for us as adults to go
back in the classroom well I think if
you're a school you have to identify who
are the high risk teachers those are
people who are elderly have medical
conditions
or who live with them and they need to
be treated slightly different than the
others who don't but you can develop a
plan for teachers who are comfortable
you're not going to force a teacher to
an uncomfortable situation but you have
to develop a plan so kids can go to
school they've done it in many countries
that's been successful children have
more maths in school all day in Japan in
South Korea in China and it's Vietnam
and they've been successful we have to
be able to do it here and we will have
very little spread at the school with a
plan where there are cases then there
will be shutdowns or ways to deal with
those cases doctor I guess the president
said yesterday we will have a vaccine in
therapeutics long before the end of the
year do you agree with that assessment
what's the timeline and more importantly
will it be effective the flu vaccine we
still need to get one every year and
it's not a catch-all glad you're asking
a lot of things at once and what I will
tell you is that the data looking
couraging now that some of the lead
vaccine candidates are causing very
potent immune responses which in general
correlate to some protection from the
virus and I emphasize the word some it's
likely that you will need two shots of
this vaccine to start so one the
beginning of one three weeks later and
then we'll see how long the vaccine
lasts you may need a booster shot every
six months every year we just don't know
yet because we're not that far into the
clinical trials but I am encouraged by
the initial data there is now the
placebo control trial ongoing in Brazil
and the power of that because Brazil has
very large numbers of cases is that we
will know soon if it works we know
there's going to be in response now
we'll know if it works if it works it's
already being produced here in the
United States there could be a vaccine
in the fall I'm optimistic but
cautiously so so dr. David agus here I
want to put a fine point on this if a
vaccine arrives in the fall does that
mean we return to normal in the fall not
at all I mean so what a vaccine will do
and this is important thank you for
asking this Tony is it will temper down
your response so you may still get the
virus but not be as sick not up in the
hospital or in an ICU and the virus can
still spread so we will still be wearing
a mask until we have a significant fall
in the virus in
sentence across the country and we will
still be to hating our behavior it is
not a one-and-done country change a shot
this will be a long procedure to get
back to normal but I do see light at the
end of the tunnel I am optimistic I like
ending on that note dr. agus thank you
very much